yeah zach
you want to start uh just by showing the
photograph that i sent you
of the uh right outside the federal
building
the the site of all of this that is
happening
um someone flying a flag and there were
a few of these someone flying an
american flag upside down
um such that it was easy to capture the
you know federal building some of the
graffiti on it
and the the fence that's been erected
around it and uh you know this is
this is a clear frankly [ __ ] america
symbol well throw flying the flag upside
down i think it's one step
more clever than that that is a
um an artifact designed for a
verificationist viewpoint
if you hate america you can find it in
the flying of that flag upside down
if you love america and you think it
needs to do better if you think things
are screwed up
you can also find it in that upside down
flag and so i think i suppose
it's actually it looks it looks i mean i
i feel like i'm a patriot who feels like
america can do better for sure
and uh and that has of course always
been true and is probably always
true for any complex political system
but
clearly we could be doing we could be
doing better and could have been doing
better and yet
it never would have occurred to me to uh
display or try to communicate any kind
of actual patriotism by
flying a flag upside down well let me
put it to you this way
if you burn a flag it's pretty
unambiguous what you mean
right if you fly a flag upside down i
truly believe
that the even just the part of the mind
that understands that to be a patriotic
symbol
gets conflicting messages and you will
be allowed to read into it whatever it
is
that you want to read into it which is
part of the problem here is that
almost everybody who is making excuses
for what's going on in portland and
elsewhere
is seeing what they want to see right
right they've had a verificationist
message put in front of them
they've had ambiguity placed where they
can do their own
some assembly required version of events
in which
you know this is peaceful protest it's
an honorable
uh tradition in america it is what the
first amendment is about
right except for the fact that there's a
reliable pattern in which
the peaceful protest descends into
violence each and every night against a
federal building
so um anyway verificationism is is
is the uh the core here yeah i think
that's right
uh zach if you want to show maybe just
10 seconds or so
of the of the video that's darker that i
that i sent you in which they're
[Music]
chanting
uh hopefully we couldn't hear that but
hopefully there was enough
being shown there that you could hear
the chance which is this sort of
atonal nasal all cops or bastards a
c a b all cops are bastards a
c a b this is not
during the part of the evening that
things began to unravel
actually this is during what is you know
would be widely considered the peaceful
protest and yet that is the chant
that is that is the chant it is clearly
divisive
and hateful and dehumanizing
and has no chance of reaching across
borders
between demographics and then finally um
the other video zak that i sent you
which is a laser there's there's no
reason i can talk over the sound on this
because i'll just describe for those
people that are not watching
there's a laser show of a
on the federal building maybe show it
again zach
of uh of a pig
wearing a police hat with x'ed out eyes
that then uh becomes [ __ ] fats
that's what it says this is being
projected from the roof of a car
at ground level onto the building
there's several projections on to the
building
yeah uh and uh
there's there's no way to unite
to imagine that the people that
that are inside that building defending
it
could come to be your friends or allies
when
this is the messaging that's out there
yeah it is designed to be
an unbridgeable gap it is designed to
make
this manifestation of our collective
self the federal government
into the enemy which is of course
preposterous and the reason that this is
desired
and plausible has to do with trump
lightning rod who couldn't possibly take
an action
that would be read as the right one if
you name an action and you say that's
what he should have done and then he
does it
it will instantly become overreach in
the minds of those
uh drawing this verificationist um
portrayal um did you want to go on to
that or
it's up to you i just thought you might
be going there uh we'll go there in a
second okay um
actually maybe we should go there first
the wall of moms okay so
uh let me say i encountered the wall of
moms
for the first time as i was riding my
bike through
downtown to get home um
and i passed by the protests and just
wanted to see what it was about and the
wall of moms was there i think it might
have been their second night in
existence
a week ago today yeah and i must say
that in looking at the wall of moms
my conclusion was much what we had heard
from the couple
of people we knew who had seen it in the
previous iteration which was that there
were people in the crowd who looked like
they might be moms but that the majority
of these people
looked like they weren't likely to be
moms and they were just dawning yellow
shirts and of course
if you think about this from the
perspective of a protest that's trying
to make a visual point
why would this be restricted to moms
when the idea is that these are
these are people who identify as moms
for the purpose of uh
making the uh response by the federal
government
look un-american right and when we were
down there
three nights ago uh we saw the the sort
of
embankment of moms before they became
the wall of mobs before they marched in
front of the federal courthouse
uh and and did the performative part of
what they do which you know i don't
think anyone's denying that
right that it's it's clearly
performative but uh what is being called
into question what we're calling into
question and what you know donald trump
called into question a lot of other
people
um is is it organic are
are these moms who felt you know the
the cry from the heart of of these other
mothers who've had their children
slaughtered by racial violence at the
hands of police
out there on the streets to decry that i
suspect that there are some people out
there who really did feel that
and are out there but um i think it
nearly impossible that it explains
everyone and i think it quite possible
and at least a hypothesis we need to be
considering
this isn't organic that it didn't start
that way at all and to that point
um i would suggest just just like we
spent some time looking at the official
black lives matter site
here's there's an official all the wall
of mom's site
uh so zach if you can show this um
it it you know begins with the hashtag
blacklivesmatter which is at least in
keeping that's on message
right and it says it says what we're
going to do but
um check out the bullet points it's not
as egregious as the black lives
matter website but it's all the same
language that we've been learning from
robin d'angelo and abram kindy
and all of this critical theory and
critical race theory stuff we listen to
black leaders we are here to follow
their direction behind the scenes and at
the justice center we go where they tell
us
that's ally ship in 2020 which is not of
course ally shep
it is a form of uh
subjugation yeah our goal it continues
is to push the media to turn the focus
where it belongs black leaders
well really because while a mom seems to
be taking a lot of the
the press at the moment we will use our
white bodies not our white voices
again with this dehumanization focus on
body
stuff um bev who was the founder of
olive's mom's
vision was that we moms would take some
physical hits and hopes that our black
and brown kids friends neighbors and
loved ones will be spared some pain
to summon that mom warrior spirit to
protect our kids all our kids
let the feds feds and cops hit gas shoot
us first not to be the voice of the
movement
this is this is picking up on not just a
trope but a
reality that actual mothers have right
that you know mother human mothers bear
mothers all mothers who have an actual
relationship with their children which
is that they
will actually put themselves in harm's
way to protect their children
and under certain circumstances um
that can be that mature that deep
abiding like deeper than anything else
maternal
instinct if you will instead probably
isn't the right word here but can be
placed onto other targets
but um this feels very much like a ploy
and in the last live stream i mentioned
naseem teles coining of the term
pedofrosty i think it was in which he he
said
this is what happens when you use
children to front
an ideology and it it it plucks at the
heartstrings of people
because you can't turn your your head or
away or your heart or your emotions away
from
from a child and a child's um you know
yearning to be heard
and to have justice done and so i
suggested that actually metro
frasty is also a thing that that is what
is going on here that it's really hard
when people are when people are making
the claim that this is a
this is this is a lot of moms in
portland who were seeing the pain of
black and brown bodies really not people
bodies okay black and brown bodies and
going out there and putting themselves
in harm's way you know presumably
at risk of if if we are to believe
the hyperbole frankly at risk of
orphaning their own children
because they feel this strongly i'm kind
of not buying it
yeah i'm just not buying it
[Music]